anna will nicht schweigen dafür riskiert
sie viel ihre Freiheit und das Leben
ihres Mannes Annas Mann kämpft in einem
Krieg den sie
ablehnt wofür überhaupt mein Mann hat
gesagt er müsse Mutter Russland
verteidigen ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass er das selbst
glaubt Soldaten frrauen wollen ihre
Männer aus der Ukraine zurück im Netz
und auf der Straße rumort es etwa in
Putins
Reich in Russland haben Soldaten Frauen
und Mütter eine Geschichte eine
Geschichte des Aufbegehrens gegen die
Männer die Russlands Kriege zu
verantworten
haben wir sind wieder da wo wir
angefangen haben kranke und schwache
werden in den Krieg geschickt wir sind
wieder an diesem völlig unnötigen Punkt
angekommen wir sind irgendwo in Russland
in einer Stadt die wir nicht nennen
können weil wir die Frau die wir hier
treffen schützen müssen wir haben für
das Interview eine Wohnung gemietet
niemand soll erkennen wer die Frau die
wir Anna nennen wirklich ist Annas Mann
kämpft seit der Mobilmachung in der
Ukraine und Anna willin
zurück mein Mann ist dagegen dass ich
das hier tue protestiere mit euch Rede
meine Schwiegereltern auch sie haben
Angst dass er dafür bestraft wird und
noch schlimmer
wird September
2022 Annas Ehemann ist einer von 300000
Russen die in den Krieg in der Ukraine
gezogen werden Mobilmachung in Russland
gibt das immer wieder zurück bleiben
Angehörige in Angst Angehörige wie
Anna es ist einfach ungerecht wenn ich
einen Soldaten geheiratet hätte dann
hätte ich dieses Schicksal gewählt mein
Mann ist aber kein Soldat es kam für
mich aus heiterem Himmel
am Jahrestag der Oktoberrevolution
tauchen in Moskau die Frauen zum ersten
Mal auf und mischen sich unter die
Kommunisten anna ist eine von ihnen sie
fordern die Heimkehr der mobilisierten
gegen den Krieg protestieren sie
nicht wir Frauen haben ganz
unterschiedliche Positionen zu diesem
Krieg manche sagen wir unterstützen
unseren Präsidenten und wir wollen das
Ansehen der Armee verbessern aber wir
sind uns dass die milisierten
zurückkommen sollen das Sehen selbst die
größten patriotinnen hier
so das Schicksal der mobilisierten
1979 die Sowjetunion marschiert in
Afghanistan ein die Ausrüstung der
jungen Rekruten ist schlecht ihre
Ausbildung noch schlechter dazu die
Erniedrigung durch die
älteren all das ruft die Mütter auf den
Plan es ist die Geburtsstunde v komite
der
Soldatenmütter Valentina melnikova war
von Anfang an
dabei es war nichts heldenhaftes als ich
1979 in der Deutschen Welle hörte dass
die Sowjets in Afghanistan
einmarschieren da habe ich mir
geschworen dass meine Söhne in keine
Armee gehen die von derart verrückten
alten Männern geführt
wird doch Mutter Russland schickt weiter
ihre Söhne in den Krieg
er
Jahren russische Mütter marschieren
Richtung Schlachtfeld und fordern ihre
Söhne die noch Kinder sind zurück auch
mit
Erfolg aber was ist davon
geblieben die sogenannte
spezialoperation ist schon der ZTE
Waffengang Russlands seit wir unser
Komitee gegründet
haben es ist
immerelbeben
dieselben Soldaten dieselben Söldner
dieselben Offiziere dieselben
Verwundeten dieselben
Kranken das ist Valentina melnika vor 30
Jahren damals war es ihr Protest als
Russlands Mütter ihre Söhne
zurückforderten und Mutter Russland sie
gewähren ließ heute ist das
andersusslandest
vorem frauen dürfen nicht über den Krieg
sprechen auf den Schildern fordern sie
die Rückkehr ihrer
Männer die Soldatenmütter damals waren
ständig im Fernsehen sie waren überall
jeder kannte sie es gab Anführerin
Valentina melnikover
z.B heute ist das anders niemand sieht
oder kennt die Köpfe hinter der Bewegung
vielleicht gibt es sie aber sie bleiben
hinter der
Bühne 7 auf der Plattform Youtube ein
gefragter Mann wir erreichen den
Journalisten in Kiev dorthin ist er aus
Russland geflüchtet für ihn fordern auch
die Frauen von heute Russlands mächtige
heraus wenn es Bilder gäbe von
Polizisten die die Frauen der
mobilisierten verprügeln oder
festnehmen stellen wir uns mal vor dass
die Bilder zu den mobilisierten Männern
im Schützengraben kämen die sterben ohne
zu wissen
wofür wennhen
fr ha verprüg wden dann würde das etwas
in Gang setzen was für die Staatsmacht
ziemlich unangenehm
wäre vielleicht riskiert Anna deshalb
das Interview mit uns sie sagt dass sie
keine Angst mehr hat dass sie nur noch
will dass dieser Albtraum
aufhört ich bete für das Ende dieses
Krieges und mein man nach Hause kommt
ges und am
Leben einfach
aufhört wie viele Frauen in diesem Land
wie Anna denken ist völlig
unklar Mutter russland hat ihre Männer
und Söhne in den Krieg geschickt und
niemand weiß ob sie jemals ob sie leben
[Musik]
zurückkommen